pouvait m'aider à porter ma glace
jusqu'à ma voiture
s'il vous plaît
c'est beau
ah la la qu'est-ce qu'il est lourde
c'est bon bah voilà nickel merci
beaucoup
a beaucoup de monde signale elle est
super lourde sous la
halle à la baraque
prenez moi à l'arrière voilà
parfait
merci aussi alors je suis vraiment
embêtés hein
qu'est ce que c'est lourd oh là là ça va
mais vous aurez super
on fait du lèche vitrine nous
c'est bon pour vous ouais c'est bon
parfait
a les yeux les yeux dessillés les îles
easy
way c'est bon vous auriez pas un chiffon
dans le coffre un truc comme ça pour
quelle est la glace
introduisez encore encore ça va s'abîmer
il faudrait vraiment un chiffon elle va
pas tomber comme ça la glace
remettez-vous au bout là parce que j'ai
peur qu'elle tombe
chercher avec moi sur ses biens
mais a trouvé un truc
merci beaucoup et c'était très sympa un
petit bisou
merci les cool temps de prendre un café
j'ai pas j'ai le droit trop un café
venez voir nos voix
[Musique]